even in our currently polarized nation  it's my hope that the fax will win the  day that the truth will always matter  that journalism and journalists will  thrive Shepard Smith  he always says breaking news changes  everything this afternoon breaking news  changed everything  breaking news that Chef was leaving Fox  News Channel his last broadcast today  you know I first started working with  Shep on my first assignment almost 23  years ago that was not it he anchored  breaking news fast moving events better  than anyone this picture actually is of  us at the Pentagon I'm at the Pentagon  live pictures coming in covering the war  in Iraq real-time and we're just  bouncing around the world with live  pictures he did it better than anybody  in the business for years and years and  years from the beginning of Fox News  Channel and I wish Shep all the best and  whatever lies ahead because Fox is less  tonight on the breaking news front  because he's not here